[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello.
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and this is your update
about the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
Drupe and Noom have
expanded globally
by localizing their
apps on Google Play.
drupe increased their
daily active users by 300%,
and actions per
average daily user
increased 25% in
the Indian market.
For more details on each, and
a link to the localization
checklist, check out the post
linked in the description
below.
Here's a cool new
open source tool
that does automatic line
breaking for Japanese
on the web.
Now, this is
particularly important
because line
breaking for Japanese
otherwise occurs
randomly-- usually,
in the middle of a word.
Now, the tool uses
Cloud Natural Language
API to analyze the
input sentence,
and it concatenates
proper words in order
to produce meaningful
chunks, utilizing
part of speech tagging
and syntactic information.
The GitHub link is on the post.
Now, there's been a major
refresh of the Google Cloud
Storage, which includes new
storage classes, data lifecycle
management tools, improved
availability, and lower
prices-- all to make it easy
for you to store your data
with the right type of storage.
More details, with charts and
examples, are on the post.
Google Stackdriver was
designed to make ops easier
by reducing the
burden associated
with keeping applications
fast, error-free,
and available in the cloud.
And it's now generally available
for hybrid cloud monitoring,
logging, and diagnostics.
For more information,
the announcement,
and how to use Stackdriver,
including code,
check out the links below.
Chrome 55 Beta is now
available with input handling
improvements, async
and await functions,
CSS automatic
hyphenation, and more.
All the details and
code are on the post.
Please subscribe and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
we'll see you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Thanks for watching yet another
episode of "The Developer
Show."
If you'd like to see some
of our previous episodes,
they're right over
here on the left.
Ooh, that's a good one.
I like this one, too.
Oh, and don't forget to
subscribe right here.